there are a ton of reasons to love car
to be okay but high to the top is the
fact that the girl keeps it real she has
been totally upfront about plastic
surgery and the painful side effect but
is cardi B really done with going under
the knife
[Music]
look how swollen my feet are y'all look
did look crazy oh my god they got even
more big I got cat going I'm a skinny
hold cardi shared this shocking pic of
her swollen feet and now just a few
months after getting lipo and her
breasts redone she's swearing off
plastic surgery from good Tweety I've
been working out for the past two weeks
cuz bleep ain't getting surgery again I
just got my boobs redone my daughter Mia
this cardi went under the knife after
the birth of now 11 month old culture
but despite strict instructions from her
doc to take it easy including no air
travel for three months she still flew
and was back on stage after a few weeks
that all party-like in a month I will be
healed and it's like wrong you really
shouldn't be having swelling this type
of complication this far out from
abdominal life was such an a breast
augmentation you may have blood clots in
the legs which is a very serious problem
plastic surgeon dr. Terry Dubrow who has
not treated Carty says the rapper could
be in real danger if it's a blood clot
you know that's a game-changer that will
sideline her for six months or more
collab people look at girls on Instagram
and think like oh they got a lipo done
and it was so easy and this is such a
long hard process so far Curry's
postponed for shows but the Palms in Los
biggest lzt she's planning to be back on
stage tomorrow
I hate counseling shows because I love
money I'm a money addict and I got paid
a lot of money
[Music]